und damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
zu einem neuen video auf einem kanal
meine lieben freunde das letzte mal dass
ich post von euch auf meinem kamera
ausgepackt habe ist leider schon sehr
sehr lange her
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
das mal wieder auf da hab ich euch in
deiner instagram story gesagt dass wenn
ihr post für mich macht also irgendein
paketen brief oder keine ahnung was er
dann schickt das gerne nach berlin an
mein management und die haben jetzt
pakete zusammengestellt und ich will
sagen wir paket nummer eins ist
aufgeschnitten meine lieben freunde und
in pakete nummer eins befinden sich drei
paketen den noch mehr
allerdings will ich sagen wir es ist so
klar gewesen das erste richtige paket
dass ich mir anschaue ist direkt wieder
ein dies hier ein bild auf dem ich eine
hässliche maske mache und hier zwei
lappen auf einem foto das kann ja nur
spaßig werden als wir haben hierzu erst
mal einen brief drin
die möchte ich nicht im video vorlesen
das habe ich auch im letzten video nicht
gemacht weil ich weiß nicht was darin
geschrieben wird und auf die person dass
mein gott ich wünschte ich hätte früher
in der schule auf bezeichnen können
sonst sind in diesem paket hier
allerdings nur noch luftschlangen drin
dennoch danke dir für deine zeichnung
und den brief werde ich mir gleich auf
kemmer durchlesen also auch danke dir
dafür würde ich sagen schauen wir uns
direkt mal das nächste paket an damit es
auch ein sehr sehr schöner karton mit
ihm zusammen mit einem vogel drauf
hatten wir auf den karton mal aus hier
vorne ist wieder einberief
kannst du mich grüßen steht hier schöne
grüße an steht aber kein name auf dem
nächsten zettel steht auch kannst du
mich grüßen
ich machte ihnen mal auf jetzt ein brief
joyce
also liebe grüße an joyce an der stelle
hier wenn dort hat sie mir geschickt hat
mir knopfes geschickt hier ist ein duplo
mit drin
also danke dir die ganze süßigkeiten
dann hat es mir noch einen tiger
geschickt dass es voll da ist weil wir
haben von diesen figürchen auch zwei
golden retriever also stelle ich den
direkt dazu oder mit dem aufreißen dann
hat ihn hierher
sie hat mir auch noch gut
beziehungsweise in wolfen gefragt diese
flächen sind auch voll teuer also mal
ganz kurz dankeschön duschgel danke
hot rod dass das ist ein paket vor allem
richtigen unternehmen um mein gott wie
süß hier sind so mein gott nein das sind
so sachen wie nennt man dazu bei dass
die man dem rund um schnell das paketes
von ella und fritz und die haben hier
ganz süßen brief dazu geschrieben und
haben vorne auf die vorderseite
berufsschule drauf geschrieben und in
dem brief steht quasi mehr oder weniger
einfach nur drin wenn du dir irgendwann
hund holen sollte bevor er mal gesagt
ich möchte und berlin denn dann hat er
jetzt auf jeden fall schon cool das
heißt es war äußerst liebe dass wir hier
ist ein foto von einem golden retriever
mit einem bendiner ich finde das so süß
hatte danke danke danke auf jeden fall
auch an euch 2 eller und fritz für das
für das nächste runde
das wird auf jeden fall demnächst
hoffentlich irgendwann gebrauch genommen
ich bin allerdings sagen die machen was
mit den nächsten pakete gehen dann
spielt ich hab soviel masse wie so wieso
schickt bei mir ein wiki und die
wikinger hörbuch wie süß und wieder da
und er ist niedrig dann ist ja auch
wieder einen brief drin und zwar kommt
das ganze von der lieben johanna brief
werde ich mir gleich durchlesen
johanna danke dir aber auf jeden fall
auch noch für die süßigkeiten hier drin
sind und die uhr
das ist eine summe von christ der löwen
und eine joschi figur ist ja auch noch
drin also danke dir auf jeden fall für
die sachen dann kommt für das gemalte
luxus schild ja und auch für das ganze
papier
falls ich irgendwann noch mal zur schule
gehen sollte werde ich auf jeden fall
gebrauchen können was ihr eigentlich
früher in der schule eher die leute die
einen karierten kutschbock hatten oder
einen linierten also ich habe egal in
welchem fach immer mit kariert
geschrieben wird wirklich immer krass
was ihr dafür aufwand reinsteckt auch
allgemeine teilweise wenn leute
allgemein soll einfach die kartons
gebastelt ich meine hier beispielsweise
bei den ersten karton gehen ich heute
ausgepackt habe so viel mühe habe ich
mir in meinen ganzen kunstunterricht
meine ganze schullaufbahn nicht gegeben
habe allerdings zu dem umschlag die
nicht gerade aufgemacht habe und zwar
jetzt
es ist ein abgetrennter kopfhörer drin
ja danke für einen kaputten airports
unter sind hier selbstverständlich auch
noch ganz viele hunde bilder mit drin
also postkarten auf denen hunde welpen
drauf sind ist auf jeden fall mega süß
dann ist hier voll und das ist doch
nicht wahr das sind das sind alles das
sind alles hunde bilder und dann noch
ein schönes bild vernichten
das nächste päckchen wird mir
zugeschickt von yu na also das packen
jetzt auch mal aus und hier steht drauf
ich möchte zu haben und das ist ein
kleines schweinchen warte ich stell dich
mal daneben so liebe julia und ein
kleines was auch immer das die iss jetzt
ist auf jeden fall neben robert robert
was hältst du davon was ist das für ein
hässliches stück scheiße alles klar
danke für deine nettigkeit immer machen
wir allerdings nun direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten paket uns war es das hier ach
du heilige scheiße ist der lego drin
also das paket das sich gerade
ausgepackt habe war halt eine große
paket zusammenstellung von studien 70
aus berlin ist schon mein management die
da halt ganz viele verschiedene verein
geschenke von euch zusammen gepackt
haben aber das hier ist alles von einer
person und ich mache es auch wenn das
erst was ich sehe ist eine menge
werbegeschenk papier dingsbums was das
werbegeschenk papier luca wo ich würde
sagen gefühl doch einfach mal rum und
sehen schon mir wurde das ist das ist
eine sehr dreckige winnie puuh puppe
also es kommt mir so vor als ob die
person sich einfach dachte ich guck mal
alles was ich meinen sie mal nicht mehr
brauchen gibt das logo weg in slate
[Musik]
wenn draußen der wind weht
das ding kann sie eigentlich doch das
haben jetzt alle mitbekommen
ich sollte ich jetzt zum ab
wir sind auf jeden fall noch mehr
süßigkeiten drin
hier sind noch so schokoladen thaler
drin also danke danke danke dir auch
dafür
es ist von samantha also aus england hat
auch ein hund und sie ist total gespannt
auf meine pizza samantha die filter
kommt auf jeden fall bald ich habe es
gestern im instagram livestream schon
gesagt als wir auf dienstag nicht folgt
laser luca da werde ich die tage auch
noch mal die fanpost mailadresse
raushauen ich möchte die fanpost adresse
halt jetzt nicht einfach hier in die
video beschreibung packen weil einfach
jetzt schon die einmal kurz meine story
geparkt nach ein paar stunden wieder
breschen das kam so viel schon wieder an
ich bin der aufnahme gerade schon bei 35
minuten und ich habe hier noch zwei
riesige pakete was ich gerade auf jeden
fall noch zulu kapitza sagen wollte wo
ich dann meine ich auch schon gestern im
instagram livestream gesagt habe ein
komplize habe ich ja eigentlich jetzt
angekündigt für den 19 11
um dem stau nein nein das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr das sieht so aus wie
ein echtes anpacker wir uns nicht klein
aber das ist ja so süß sind überall so
ein bisschen konfetti hier dran aber an
danke danke danke auf jeden fall für
dieses einfacher der briefe oder jedes
paket ist von
was ist das was ist das hier das ist die
fahrt kann dass die anderen auch der
andere ist einfach ekelhaft er ist das
süß man das ist nicht wahr
wally und jamie sie heißt auf instagram
starbucks luca und lukas clouds also
schaut auf jeden fall gern mal bei den
beiden vorbei danke euch für dieses mega
süße alpaka das werde ich da oben
hinstellen und da wird es demnächst im
hintergrund von meinen videos sein dass
ich allerdings eigentlich zulu kapitza
sagen wollte war dass ich ja eigentlich
den 19 11
als termin angepeilt habe dass sie da
raus kommt die sache ist allerdings wir
haben uns jetzt auf den ersten zwölfter
kommunikativ geeinigt weil die sache es
geht nicht so ein launch sein wie
beispielsweise im juca shop dass man
einfach sagt hey die sachen sollen jetzt
online geht man drückt auf den knopf
sondern die rewe-märkte können und quasi
schon jetzt die pizzen ordern
das heißt es kann sein dass in eurem
supermarkt nebenan jetzt schon di luca
pizza drei liegen wird was ist hier drin
also spätestens ab dem ersten zwölf wird
ist die pizza 3 in den meisten rewe
edeka märkten in deutschland geben
die sache ist jeder rewe markt bzw jeder
edeka markt hat die möglichkeit im café
23 zu bestellen
ach das ist mein gott das riecht so
gailer ferrero küsschen
danke auf jeden fall für dieses paket
hier ist auch noch so niedrig
ich weiß nicht wann ich warte ist das
das also dass gesorgt jeden fall von ich
kann nicht lesen
dank dir auf jeden fall trotzdem für
sein paket und für die süßigkeiten was
mit dem eigenen ist weiß ich jetzt nicht
könnt ihr mich immer gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben aber jetzt mal kurz
um das thema abzuschließen also die
pizza wird es auf jeden fall ab den
ersten zwölf richtig geben
sie sagte dass nämlich das am 11 12 der
reva handzettel rauskommt ganz kurz ich
weiß nicht dafür aber viel zu schnell
ablenken aber ich finde es so süß wie
hier die kartons einfach die sein werden
ich meine schaut euch das hier an
das ist einfach ich mache den karton auf
und auf jeder seite steht was und auch
hier von den seiten des auch wieder
alles voll geklebt worden
ich hab's gar nicht verdient dass ihr
euch solche mühe gebt einfach für mich
kleinen voll spaß tier vor der kamera an
rieter danke euch auf jeden fall für das
paket stehen hier die ganzen sachen ich
glaube das will ich jetzt zu lange
dauern wenn ich das alles in dem video
auspacken würde ich werde auf jeden fall
auspacken aber hey allein wie viel mühe
die sicht lasst das finde ich allein
schlimmer kasten wie viel mühe die sich
dann mit denen mit dem karton mission
geben komme auch unten drin so von wegen
hey wenn er die sachen ausgepackt hat
dann sieht er noch das hier und dann
alles auch freudig ich fühle mich
richtig scheiße ich habe das nicht
verdient sondern riesa haben wir da auf
jeden fall 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 kleine pakete
noch eingepackt im aber ich glaube das
sind also ich glaube dass dann alle
süßigkeiten danke euch auf jeden fall
einfach nur mir wird schlecht wenn ich
einfach nur die karton geschickt hätte
so keine ahnung und das letzte paket für
das heutige video meine lieben freunde
ich da aber das ist das video auch lang
genug ist ein paket von der person
namens zoe aus hanau johanna oder war
ich schon es eine coole stadt allein
dass leute sich die mühe gemacht haben
zum postkasten zu sein beziehungsweise
paketen halten post wirklich zu rennen
und diese pakete abzuschicken zeigte
schon dass ich würde mir kein paket
schicken machen wir das paket jetzt
allerdings mal auf und wir haben
zuallererst einen brief drinnen lese ich
mir gleich durch man hier noch einen
brief verlesen wir auch schon ganz
wieder süßigkeiten wieder etwas teurer
ich freue mich immer nicht so richtig
diese sachen auspacken wenn ihr ein pink
glänzender hirschi habe auf jeden fall
ganz viel schokolade drin wir haben hier
weingummis denn wir haben kettcar wir
haben kinder schokolade wir haben lollis
amnesty wieder was in zeitungspapier
eingefasst
da schauen wir nochmals nach darin
findet sich auch ein paar zu papa ich
mache doch jetzt kein passender auf
hatte hier sieht auch schon aus wie bei
hempels mir den ganzen verpackungen aber
danke dir auf jeden fall auch meine
liebe war die sie aus hannover
danke dir auch für deinen paket den
brief setze ich mich gleich durch
allerdings würde ich an der stelle das
heutige video ist auch beendet meine
lieben freunde wo ich stehe gerade noch
in süßigkeiten wenn es das heutige video
erfahren hat dass unbedingt einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da schreibt
mir zu dem witzigen und in die
kommentare ob ich das noch mal hoch
laden soll
wir haben noch ganz viel fern geschenke
von euch in berlin liegen dann würde ich
den jungs einfach sagen es schick doch
mal rüber dann mache ich irgendwann ein
zwei wochen noch mal ein video also
abonniert gerne unter dem video machen
kanal damit ihr das nächste fanpost
auspacken video mit luca nicht verpasst
er noch mal kurz luca pizza wie bereits
gesagt erste zwölfter ist die rauskommen
hier muss jetzt glaube ich werbe video
einblenden ziemlich gerade ganz
eingeblendet und ja ich hoffe ihr freut
euch drauf
wir wollten noch ein anders ganz diesem
eher so aus hanau
[Musik]